de la gastronomie considéré comme ceux
qui a privilégié de l'économie dès 2004
la fort de san diego à ses clients de
les appeler chaque année
les quais douche
et bien présent
des centaines de personnes on peut
regarder travailler les artisans
demander des conseils dit et les
produits c'est un peu la fête et la
découverte globale d'un artisanat
aliments perdus
avec une foire exposition de cette
manifestation devant public
et que la gastronomie
tout à fait
l'intérêt particulier en victime s'est
clos france est bien la bonne bouffe on
dire est que la casc demi a toujours un
énorme succès et nous avons l'intention
de poursuivre dans cette voie en
valorisant même les grands chefs du
département participantes rosa sociaux
et d'astronomie
dix associations culinaires la sauce au
curry nerfs des côtes d'armor également
tablé gens de qualité donc c'était c'est
une occasion de promouvoir un petit peu
les grands chefs du département à
travers la gastronomie à travers
l'agroalimentaire cette représentation
gastronomie fait la chambre de métiers
de saint brieuc c'est une référence
puisqu'elle débloque
vraiment
on a su mieux
vitrine du savoir faire
parce que nous
koné gastronomique est excellent taux
n'est pas mauvais pour les intérêts
il ya beaucoup d'atouts en bretagne mais
la gastronomie est primordial on ne peut
promouvoir le tourisme
on ne peut pour promouvoir une région
sans bonne gastronomie les bretons sont
très forts pour cela et ils ont de très
bons produits et je dirais que
c'est à double effet puisque on parle
matériel que nous fabriquons pour les
métiers alimentaires
nous avons une industrie qui fabrique du
matériel des tables des fours etc pour
les métiers de l'alimentation
nous avons les produits de la mer les
produits de la terre
donc il y a un intérêt économique
capital samedi une nouvelle boucle et
gastronomique verra le jour celle de la
capitale
animation supplémentaire
elle est allée chez coûte
général
et il avait une tête
voir avec ces quatre sont des choses
ils sont chaque année tous